and tonight a shout-out for a reporter
whose investigation into the white/black
disparity of two high schools in
Louisiana gave voice to the students who
are getting the short end of the
educational stick and got the attention
of the federal judge overseeing the
school district the mold the carpet the
walls itself the classrooms the teachers
everything that you need in the school
or could use in the school is not there
reporter Dan Lieberman the online media
outlet now this went to Catahoula Parish
in Louisiana to block high school where
most of the students are
african-american to see why students are
speaking out in what conditions and deep
south schools are like more than six
decades after desegregation we saw a
local news piece from rural Louisiana
about these kids were protesting
conditions at their high school what
you're doing how you expect me to do I
talked with Lieberman at the now the
studios in New York where the kids
afraid to speak out where they afraid
they might be punished by the school
they were surprised to see that that
someone from out of town out of state
was showing up to really put a spotlight
on these issues they weren't sure it was
going to make much of a difference
because they really felt like in this
parish in this state they're their
voices didn't matter and they weren't
gonna get a change what made the stories
so powerful is what Lieberman then
discovered nearby but 13 miles away
there's another school in the same
school district that looks a lot
different nearly 90 percent of the
senior class here is white they perform
better academically and enroll in
college at a higher rate it really did
feel wrong it felt like an injustice
this is one School District the schools
should not look that different and that
you know that there's been desegregation
orders in place since the 1960s
and
for you know if you're in eleventh and
twelfth grade at one school
majority-white other school
majority-black
you look at the conditions of the two
high schools and and you see that the
funding doesn't add up so we just tried
to film inside Harrisonburg high school
but the superintendent won't let our
cameras inside they don't want the
principal's to talk to us on camera but
there's a clear notable difference in
how the school looks compared to black
high school but Lieberman was able to
get the superintendent on camera when we
talked to students and we talked to
families at black high school they
compared it to Harrisonburg they say
Harrisonburg has beautiful facilities
why do you think they're saying there's
such a difference several of the other
schools communities of passed Bondi
she's specifically around facility
renovation and refurbishment and in the
recent years Johnsville hasn't passed
any such issue to address their schools
both high schools are in the same
district and Lieberman says he thinks
there's more to it than bond issues
after talking to one school board member
so I asked the school board member why
don't we just consolidate the schools
and she said the parents at that school
they don't want their kids going to
school with those kids because of their
moral character that's what she said
yeah when it was what a big load for
because it's a code for racism it's it
and it it was so it was so obvious you
feel it there and it was wrong
Lee Berman's report had immediate impact
federal judge Dedra overseeing the long
delayed desegregation efforts in that
school district saw the now this report
and ordered a hearing into what's going
on so essentially he was unaware of this
disparity until your report that's right
so he gave you full credit for bringing
this to his attention and either the
school board
or the Justice Department had done that
he said I'm he said that I'm so glad you
came down
Louisiana why do you think it took an
outsider to go down there and to reveal
this to me I really think that it speaks
to the broader crisis and journalism
where areas like this in the deep south
in rural areas they're not getting asked
tough questions reporters are not
showing up they're asking tough
questions but now they will have to
answer tough questions from a federal
judge judge drill at a hearing scheduled
for next month so a shout out to
reporter Dan Lieberman who I'm proud to
say began his professional career
working with me as a young man at the
ABC News investigative unit he's
continuing to make everyone so proud
that's our program for this week thanks
for joining us we'll see you right back
here next week good night